okay  what happened me laughing you came home  you went to bed  oh no no no that is not what happened  you're scaring me  he talks doctory okay Gabrus tell me  about these dreams even Alex still they  just feel real apple subconscious dream  can become borderline concept like  you're awake but you'll still dream mine  waking dreams and listen people killing  them am I going crazy no  23 I never want to do you any harm  very dangerous thought you can are done  being your puppet  years of research on that boy  hi waiting all day to do that  breem of freedom it's over less personal  McGill is you take what we want what we  don't want with you  you  you